TEAM DURANT.
TEAM DURANT WILL GIVE THEIR BEST
TONIGHT TO BENEFIT THE GREATER
CLEVELAND FOOD BANK.
>>> ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS TEAM DURANT.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MEET THEIR
COMPETITION.
AND TO HELP ME OUT THIS TIME,
I'M BRINGING A LITTLE MAGIC FROM
LOS ANGELES, IT'S THE MAGIC MAN
HIMSELF.
MAGIC, TAKE IT AWAY.
>>> THIS TEAM HAS IT ALL.
THEY GOT CHAMPIONS, MVPs, YOUTH
AND EXPERIENCE, BRAWN AND BRAINS
AND THEY CAN DOMINATE THE PAINT
AND SHOOT THEIR THING FROM DEEP.
I PUT THEM UP AGAINST ANYONE,
THIS IS TEAM LeBRON!
>> APPEARING IN HIS FIRST
ALL-STAR GAME AS A HEAD COACH,
FROM THE DEFENDING WESTERN
CONFERENCE CHAMPION PHOENIX
SUNS, MONTY WILLIAMS!
AND NOW LET'S MEET OUR RESERVES,
SELECTED BUT UNABLE TO ATTEND,
THREE-TIME ALL STAR FROM THE
UTAH JAZZ, DONOVAN MITCHELL.
INJURED AND UNABLE TO PLAY FOR
TEAM LeBRON IS A TEN-TIME
ALL-STAR FROM THE PHILADELPHIA
76ERS, JAMES HARDEN!
HE'S MAKING HIS ALL-STAR GAME
DEBUT, ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
PLAYERS IN THE LEAGUE FROM YOUR
CLEVELAND CAVALIERS, GIVE IT UP
FOR DARIUS GARLAND!
HE'S ALSO MAKING HIS ALL-STAR
GAME DEBUT, HE'S THE MAN IN THE
MIDDLE JARRETT ALLEN!
AND MAKING HIS ALL-STAR DEBUT
FROM THE TORONTO RAPTORS, FRED
VanVLEET!
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST POINT
GUARDS IN THE GAME MAKING HIS
THIRD ALL-STAR APPEARANCE, FROM
THE DALLAS MAVERICKS, LUKA
DONCIC!
A SIX-TIME ALL-STAR WHO GETS
BUCKETS FOR THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE LEADER, MIAMI HEAT
JIMMY BUTLER!
THE FIRST PLAYER IN NBA HISTORY
TO RACK UP 20,000 POINTS AND
10,000 ASSISTS, MAKING HIS 12th
ALL-STAR GAME APPEARANCE FROM
THE PHOENIX SUNS, THE POINT GUY,
CHRIS BALL!
AND NOW LET'S MEET THE STARTERS
FOR TEAM LeBRON.
HE'S THE BIG MAN FROM THE DENVER
NUGGETS, THE REIGNING NBA MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER, THE JOKER,
NIKOLA JOKIC!
ONE MAKING HIS FIFTH ALL-STAR
GAME APPEARANCE FROM THE CHICAGO
BULLS, DeMAR DEROZAN!
HE'S THE GREATEST THREE-POINT
SHOOTER IN NBA HISTORY, A
TWO-TIME LEAGUE MVP, A
THREE-TIME NBA CHAMPION AND AN
EIGHT-TIME ALL-STAR, FROM THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS, STEPHEN
CURRY!
HE'S BEEN NAMED DEFENSIVE PLAYER
OF THE YEAR AND EARNED MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER HONORS TWICE,
THE MVP OF THE 2021 NBA FINALS
FROM THE DEFENDING CHAMPION
MILWAUKEE BUCKS, GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO!
A FOUR-TIME CHAMPION, A
FOUR-TIME MOST VALUABLE PLAYER,
A FOUR-TIME NBA FINALS MVP, THE
LEADING SCORER IN ALL-STAR
HISTORY MAKING HIS 18th ALL-STAR
ON THIS STAGE, HE'S JUST A KID
FROM AKRON FROM THE L.A. LAKERS,
LeBRON JAMES!
LET'S GIVE IT UP ONE MORE TIME
FOR TEAM LeBRON!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
TEAM LeBRON WILL BE PLAYING HARD
FOR THE KIDS DAY SCHOLAR
PROGRAM.
>> THERE IT IS, EVERYONE.
THE MATCH IS SET UP.
TEAM LeBRON VERSUS TEAM DURANT,
IT'S NBA ALL-STAR 2022.
CLEVELAND, STAND UP AND MAKE
SOME NOISE.
THANK YOU FOR JOININGS PARTY.
EVERYBODY, ENJOY THE GAME!
>>> FANS, LET'S HEAR IT ONE MORE
TIME FOR MACHINE GUN KELLY,
D-NICE, DIRK NOWITZKI, MAGIC
JOHNSON AND YOUR